et
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
philippe collin bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation êtes producteur de radio
auteur journaliste les auditeurs de
france inter vous connaissent bien le
mois dernier vous avez publié une
enquête historique fouillé sur sur
philippe pétain à la fois on podcast une
série d'une dizaine de 10 épisodes d'une
cinquantaine de minutes et et en livre
le fantôme de philippe pétain aux
éditions flammarion d'abord pourquoi
vous intéressez à la figure de philippe
pétain et pourquoi maintenant et vous
savez le mot fantôme à un synonyme en
français qui est revenant à un fantôme
c'est un revenant et philippe pétain
depuis qu'il est mort en 1951 à l'âge de
95 ans est revenu plusieurs fois dans le
débat politique français et nous avons
vu ces derniers mois ces dernières
années même là depuis 2018 un retour de
philippe pétain en tout cas de la figure
de philippe état dans le débat public
français et je me suis posé la question
de savoir ce qui se cachait derrière
cette énième retour en 2018 2022 de la
figure du vieux maréchal en france et
donc avec 12 historia parce que philippe
pétain est un dossier complexe et
parfois dangereux nous sommes attelés à
essayer de comprendre de quoi pétain
était le nom et de quoi pétain et le nom
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se cache
derrière cette histoire avec une
question sous-jacente qui est pas de
savoir ce que nous aurions fait en mai
juin 1940 on sait déjà tout se poser la
question et personne n'a la réponse la
question est plutôt de savoir quel
citoyen français je suis aujourd'hui
face à l'héritage de philippe pétain
entre guillemets héritage et face à
l'histoire du régime de vie si il ya une
chose que vous évoquez notamment c'est
cette affiche de de philippe pétain sur
laquelle pendant l'occupation il était
inscrit il est plus français que vous et
vous êtes posé la question mais de quel
droit ce qui serait plus français que
man absolument la question c'était êtes
vous plus français que lui c'était la
campagne d' affiches officielles l'une
des campagnes d'affichage de la france
de vichy exactement mais ça dit beaucoup
de choses ça dit que philippe état en
creux à une vision de la france à une
définition de la france qu'il appelle
france éternelle se joue beaucoup de
choses là c'est à dire que cette france
internet c'est une france contre
révolutionnaire une france
antirépublicaine une france de la
révolution nationale ce programme
politique où il s'agit d'exclure les
mauvais français de la société française
c'est à dire qu'il a un rapport
pratiquement médical au corps social il
ya donc des gens qui sont là en france
et qui sont qui actent son actif contre
la france éternelle et il faut les
exclure ça veut dire faut exclure les
juifs les francs maçons les gaullistes
les socialistes les communistes il y a
un bon français aux yeux de philippe
pétain et les autres sont des ennemis de
la france donc il faut s'en débarrasser
voilà pour régénérer la société
exactement ces douze historiens vous
avez rencontré deux femmes un homme est
ce qui nous ont tous le même point de
vue sur philippe est un nom il y a des
points 2 2 comme moi dire de débats sur
philippe pétain dans le cadre d'une
science humaine c'est à dire l'histoire
est une science avec des protocoles donc
il y a des règles à respecter mais dans
ce cadre des règles il ya des points de
vue opposés par exemple le chapitre ii
est consacré à la première guerre
mondiale deux historiens nicolas
offenstadt stéphane audoin-rouzeau deux
sommités mondiales de la première guerre
mondiale ils ont des points de vue
opposés sur philippe états dans le cadre
la première guerre mondiale d'eau qui a
déjà des lignes de fracture mais
toujours sur le répète dans le cadre de
l'histoire puisque on n'est pas là pour
transformer une opinion en vérité
l'historien à des outils à respecter les
protocoles notamment les archives et
c'est important de le dire parce qu'on a
subi ces derniers mois une sorte
d'assaut de vouloir transformer des
opinions en vérité historique à propos
de philippe pétain ce qui est toujours
un peu à la fois déstabilisant
exaspérant transformer des opinions
fesses et c'est quelque chose qui était
la mode au-delà du cas sauvignon pétain
vous raconter l'histoire de cet orphelin
de mère le fils de la morte qui va
devenir le vainqueur de verdun bientôt
étouffée par la vanité fossoyeurs de la
république ensuite à la tête du pays
vous décrivez sa révolution nationale
axée sur sa devise travail famille
patrie on pourrait rajouter également la
religion sont en tiff de sémitisme
polymorphe son faux amis laval l'exil en
allemagne puis sa condamnation ses
traces dans l'histoire pour les français
pendant des années pétain c'est d'abord
le héros de la première guerre mondiale
presque par hasard à par hasard il ya la
bataille de verdun est déterminant pour
lui et c'est dûment il faut savoir que
aumoite au printemps 1914
ip temps et colonels et s'apprête à
partir à la retraite vous comprenez
c'est à dire que c'est fini et ja des 14
des 14es l'état majeur il a 58 ans on
maîtrise alors au 19e siècle il est né
en 1956 exactement de qui là il a 58 ans
il s'apprête à partir à la retraite et
on lui a refusé le grade de général
d'ailleurs et du coup la première
gagnante elle arrive comme une aubaine
quasiment ce militaire qui n'a jamais
combattu se retrouvent appelé à la
rescousse de l'armée française en 1916
février puisque la ligne française
risque d'être percés par les allemands
donc on appelle ce général inconnu au
bataillon entre guillemets qui va donc
nous est là avec les français une
relation extrêmement particulière à la
fois réputé sauveur de verdun est aussi
celui qui va prendre soin des hommes
c'est à dire que l'année 1917 d'avoir
des mutineries dans l'armée française et
philippe et havas avoir réglé ce
problème de drh quelque part à dire
qu'il ya des preuves de ressources
humaines il a peur d'être un général la
défaite par abandon et par parent grève
dans l'armée française et donc il à
prendre des mesures pour prendre soin du
poilu n'ont pas joué par désir humaniste
je le répète mais par souci de stratégie
mais ça va nouer entre lui et les
français un rapport extrêmement
particulier presque affectif et
irrationnelle et qui va marquer toute
son existence parce que vous le disiez
pour la première guerre mondiale c'est
pas lui qui se propose on va le chercher
exactement et c'est d'abord l'histoire
d'un ego d'un orgueil qui va grandir
jusqu'à son procès même dans ces
derniers jours de liberté quand il
quitte son exil en suisse et qu'il
arrive en france y pense encore qu'il va
être acclamé et qui va être saluée il
accepte les louanges il se persuade
qu'il est le meilleur qu'il a les
meilleures valeurs qui va se laisser
emporter par une extrême droite dont il
partage les idées
comment est-ce que ce vainqueur de
verdun d'abord va tomber en politiqué et
suivre ses appels du pied alors il tombe
en politique en 1934 lorsqu'après la
crise du 6 février 34 ou la république
est menacée gares entre 15 et 30 morts a
paris une manifestation d'extrême droite
qui veut renverser la république on
appelle gaston doumergue pour créer un
gouvernement d'union nationale dans
lequel va entrer philippe pétain comme
ministre de la guerre ça va durer neuf
mois mais c'est intéressant de le dire
parce que c'est une expérience qui est
compliqué pour philippe était en sortie
de sept ministères il dira je hais la
politique et les politiciens parce que
vous savez on parlemente en politique un
parlement c'est pour discuter on discute
on est l'art du compromis la république
et philippe et atteint militaire et il
n'aime pas trop discuté il aime qu'on
réponde aux ordres c'est le culte du
chef avec une culture militaire tout
simplement et donc philippe pétain après
1934 à se piquer de politique et va tout
doucement seul et s'est entouré de
personnes qui vont se projeter en lui
comme un possible recours face à une
france qui pourrait s'effondrer
arrivé d'ailleurs et donc il va voir là
une sorte de alors c'est intéressant
parce que il va avancer masqué quand
même à dire que philippe état n'est pas
du tout marquée à l'extrême droite à la
fin des années 30 c'est un homme de
droite réactionnaire militaire
nationaliste annonce de se charger il va
à des règlements complètement la pensée
extrêmement exactement mais très vite
lorsqu'il prend le pouvoir donc le 10
juillet 1940 en effet surgi là un
programme politique
travail famille patrie la révolution
nationale et qui va donc avoir une
obsession dès le départ c'est d'exclure
des le dès le 22 juillet 1940 on prend
des lois pour des naturalisés les
mauvais français et effectivement il a
avec lui une sorte de groupe autour de
lui qui a réfléchi un programme
politique et qui vont très vite entre en
action puisque rappelons que dès le 3
octobre 1940 il y à un premier statut
des juifs promulguée et les et les
paiements des allemands absolument et
durcit durci de la main de philippe
pétain qui va donc choisir d'exclure les
juifs de toute la fonction publique
française et il va profiter un profiter
bon en tout cas vivre de cette fracture
très importante car la société française
vous dites que que la france en 1940 et
est prête finalement à et bien une
dictature en tout cas un régime
autoritaire ça c'est une question
extrêmement délicate et et sensible
parce qu'en effet notamment parce
calorique et dans l'académie siens
historiens dans le livre pose cette
question en effet est ce que la société
française en 1939
désir un pouvoir autoritaire c'est une
question compliquée il ya une crise
d'identité nationale dans les années
trente et un repli sur soi on a peur de
beaucoup de choses la violence des
vagues d'immigration val d'immigration
et puis on est on est on traverse une
grande crise économique politique donc
on a une sorte de repli sur soi aux
frontières des pouvoirs autoritaires
comme hitler comme mussolini laisse à
croire que c'est efficace donc on peut
se demander si effectivement cette
france qui a testé entre guillemets le
front populaire en 36 n'est pas attirée
par un pouvoir ou le l'exécutif serait
plus fort et pourraient être imputés
dans un militaire et le jeu maréchal
pétain ferait figure parfaite de cette
incarnation de valises c'est compliqué
parce que peut-être en effet
une large partie de la population
française aspirait à un pouvoir
autoritaire mais c'est une question très
complexe parce que ça a laissé entendre
que philippe pétain est arrivé aussi par
désir du peuple français donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué en fait vos
entretiens ils sont ponctuées
d'occasions manquées pour pétain des
occasions manquées de deux de faire
machine arrière
refuser la politique d'abord à
l'entre-deux-guerres il aurait très bien
pu prendre sa retraite est une
historienne qu'ils disent ils avaient
été remparts et et s'il avait arrêté sa
carrière en 36 sur et les avenues
philippe pétain partout en france il
aurait pu rester un héros refuse la
capitulation il aurait pu refuser cet
antisémitisme d'état plutôt que d'aller
plus loin que demander les nazis refusé
de partir en exil en allemagne refusé de
rentrer en france pour son procès
qu'est-ce qu'il avait glissé son orgueil
à nouveau alors là c'est pour moi le
mystère philippe pétain c'est à dire que
malgré mon enquête il reste des zones
d'ombré philippe et un en effet il ya
peut-être un ressort chez lui d'une d'un
grand orgueil d'une grande vanité
qu'il fait qu'il s'accroche jusqu'au
bout il est obsédé par sa popularité
philippe pétain donc tout au long de sa
vie il y as peut-être ce désir là de ne
pas lâcher la rampe comme on dit
vulgairement jusqu'à noué un pacte
faustien c'est à dire qu' il va troquer
sa gloire éternelle contre la prise du
pouvoir avec la conviction absolue
d'avoir raison ça c'est le second
ressort chez pétain la conviction
absolue d'avoir toujours raison et
d'être le sauveur de la france éternelle
donc il ce ressort là aussi à la fois
vaniteux certes mais aussi une
conviction le complètement dépassé
heures puisqu'il ne comprend pas ce qui
se passe philippe était en vérité ne
sait pas qui est hitler il ne compte ne
comprend pas qu'il y à là dans le
nazisme une violence intrinsèque total 1
mais philippe et 1 g habité par cette
conviction sans doute d'être celui qui
sait à la place des autres conviction
que porte encore certains de ses
partisans aujourd'hui cet héritage de
philippe pétain dans la société
française on retrouve également dans ce
livre je suis désolé c'est tout le temps
qu'on a malheureusement pour cette
immersion devoir rendre l'antenne c'est
absolument passionnant fantôme de
philippe pétain aux éditions flammarion
et en podcast il ya dix épisodes et
c'est absolument passionnant
et important écouter dans l'époque qu'on
est en train de traverser merci d'avoir
c'est moi qui vous remercie merci
beaucoup merci à